eh bien au jour les amis nous sommes
aujourd'hui avec l'inter acide et
maxence ou coup on soir vous avez
vraiment répondu en choeur et avec
synchronisation je suis stupéfait
aujourd'hui on est sur comédie night
c'est un jeu que j'ai découvert grâce à
l'unc et erratique un jeu très amusant
que c'est un jeu qui simule une soirée
dans laquelle n'importe qui va pouvoir
aller sur scène du coup chacun pourra
prendre la parole sur scène pour lancer
un thème ou raconter ce qu'il veut ou
faire des blagues va s'amuser je vais
twitté le lien de la salle pour que les
gens puissent venir à notre soirée
basque sortu n'applaudit pas quand je
sais pas dit d'applaudir s'te plaît
excuse moi on est parti les amis tout
monde a compris le principe du jeu on
invite les gens à nous rejoindre
allez c'est parti memscap stop tu n'es
pas monter sur scène juste et le rythme
tellement vidé sur ce grave c'est
incroyable on accueille plusieurs arcs
enix monyetta ue chine buy me love
ranelagh
bienvenue c'est non alors je vais
appeler l'un de vous au pif et il va
devoir mettre de l'ambiance avec la
technique qu'il veut je fais mon petit
tirage au sort attention suspense
et ces cris sauveur qui monte sur scène
c'est pour moi
moi je reviens des toilettes et je me
demandais de kouman feuilles de toi de
papier toilette doit utiliser par
essuyage alors ça c'est une bonne
question mais ça dépend des moments
en fait parce que quand on en fait ça
dépend la qualité du pq est ce que c'est
pas plus malins d'acheter un pq plus
épais mais plus cher que d'acheter un pq
moins épais mais moins cher il faudrait
faire le calcul
je le demandais ce que quand on utilise
un essor trois feuilles utilisée trois
fois mais qui manquent d'eau saine
atteinte à temps grâce fait cette
réflexion sur scène parce que ça vaut le
coup ok d'amir d'innocenter compter
qu'on peut être la question à l'heure
c'était difficile alors j'ai dit
question damian et tu dépressif ou
drogué ouest à poster d'être sous
l'emprise de stupéfiants je me tiens ma
réponse je ne viens pas je suis là pour
répondre aux questions de vote alors tu
achètes du pq triple épaisseur toi c'est
ça ouais donc est ce que ça veut dire
bien tristement moins cher ouais mais
bon tu mens 3 épaisseurs
c'est quoi le sais quoi qui baisse et le
déplacer le débat les gens veulent
savoir qu'on se mobilise
on se mobilise
résidant à lui faut le garder bon
déroulement d'un milliard d'âmes et à
tous à la révolution et tout à propos du
pq c'est cool mais faut penser à
descendre de scène
ok je suis un peu emporté
non mais c'est cool c'est cool alors à
propos du caca j'ai une anecdote quand
j'étais à l'école j'avais un pote qui
pouvaient pas sauter de faire caca mais
c'est une vraie maladie en veine de
pauvres dès que sa santé le caca dans la
classe tout le monde le regarde et est
souvent basses et qui s'était fait caca
dessus le dos nu des lots je sais plus
comment il s'appelle
laissez moi finir plus tard on est en
fait un jour on a vu dans ces crayons de
couleur il y avait marqué et avait
marqué toxiques et comme miles et 8 ans
kaka va tout le monde s'est moqué de lui
peu horrible et du coup si tu regarde
cette vidéo je fais plutôt non mais
j'aimerais m'excuser au nom de tous
d'avoir rigolé parce que tu étais pas du
tout toxiques
tu étais vraiment respectable et c'est
pas ta faute si tu faisais caca dessus
bravo merci si aujourd'hui vous voulez
faire passer un message à quelqu'un qui
regardera probablement cette vidéo et
baal et si c'est le moment là chez vous
et faites vos confession allez-y alors
noémie excuse moi te mettre moqué dans
sa couleur de cheveux blonds parce que
c'est un peu moche c'est un truc de ouf
photo collège ont parfaitement joué un
coup qui tu sais pas pourquoi on rien
c'est parce qu'on avait remplacé les
pépites de chocolat par des petites
crottes de chiens non je suis désolé aux
produits les lions parce qu'il avait
oublié ses clés sur son pied et je les
ai foutu dans les chiottes et j'étais la
chasse et ça met plus le vélo dalle
un jour j'étais très méchant avec une
fille au lycée
moi je vais pas dire son prénom parce
que j'étais monde que je veux pas
qu'elle me reconnaissent on était saine
fille qui voulait rentrer tout le temps
entre avec moi au lycée dans le bus on
prenait le pulse ensemble et rejoueront
rentrer en bus il n'y avait plus que
tous deux dans le bus et elle était
endormie est on arrivé au dernier rush
descendait et du coup je me retourne et
je me dis merde qu'est ce que je fais tu
vois j'ai eu à passer s'est passé dans
ma tête je me dis merde
est ce que je la réveille ou quoi je
n'ai pas réveiller et le bus est parti
et je pense qu'elle est allée au garage
je suis désolé qu'est ce que vous voulez
alors damian j'aimerais que tu nous
disent comment tu es sorti avec ta
première copine comment l'as-tu séduit
[Musique]
chez ont tous choisi brocade du hip hop
et me jean damy à je me permet de
dégager le grand seigneur de scène juste
parce que à cause i c'est un truc à dire
ça lui a causé sa petite question je
sais pas si leur prix n'est qu'une fête
sous la douche baisses sont beaucoup
plus forts on en vient aux problèmes des
3 alors après ce débat on va rester dans
le caca parce qu'on adore ça ce qu'on va
faire maintenant c'est que quand on
monte sur scène on dit une anecdote qui
fait qu'on se pose une question depuis
tout ce temps dont on n'a jamais eu la
réponse je m'explique quand j'étais plus
jeune à l'école primaire dans mon cas je
suis allé aux toilettes et j'ai fait un
caca jaune très jaune et je ne sais
toujours pas à quoi c'est lié donc si
quelqu'un a la réponse ce soir
j'aimerais qu'il éclaire ma lanterne non
mais c'est pas normal sans voix c'est le
genre de l'alimentation je pense que tu
as mangé dans trop de légumes ou trop de
fibres en fait trop de fibreuse pas je
sais pas exactement terre mais mais vous
regardez vous
tous votre caca bon alors fait caca mais
tu sais tu sais que c'est important de
le faire parce que tu peux avoir des
maladies et tout et c'est ton caca qui
te l'indiquent quoi donc vraiment à
chaque fois au fait quelqu'un vous
regardez dans la cuvette comme cheikh
sarr à regarder en même temps c'est est
ce qu'il ya des anecdotes où vous vous
trouviez un peu con que vous êtes et il
faisait les petites à moyennes que vous
croyez j'en ai une journée en fait je
croyais que le vent il été créé par les
arbres voilà parce que je voyais les
hawks agitée et je crois qu'en fait tu
les a créés devront à cette très mignon
voilà alors moi je croyais que ce qu'on
avait dans les oreilles c'était de la
cire humaine mais en fait pas du tout à
classique
en fait ça s'appelle du cérumen et c'est
un nom scientifique voilà moi je me
souviens dans ma mère une fille m'a dit
t'es bien dans sa peau moi je croyais
que j'en juge avait assez de pau dans
mon corps bah ouais je me sens bien
mieux dans ma peau quoi faire en voiture
la suite et j'avais peur mais demandé ce
que c'était elle m'a dit un tremblement
de terre et pendant très longtemps j'ai
coster pour un inventaire à chaque fois
qu'on passait sur deux états j'étais
gosse j'étais persuadé que c'était
quelqu'un qui me retourner dans mon
sommeil
c'est à dire que quand on dort on se
tourne sans rappel pas le lendemain
matin qui m'avait retourné le lendemain
jean guy l'été monde pour savoir qui
s'était jetée de ma gueule quand on
désire pas quitter retourner tout seul
c'est normal et des gens non le mec n'a
pas dormi pendant trois ans pour
comprendre moi j'ai une anecdote mais je
pense que tout le monde l'a en fait
quand justement j'étais genre avec mon
père en voiture à chaque fois qu'il
remercie quelqu'un d'un signe de la main
je croyais qu'il connaissait la personne
en fait à chaque fois échoué et qu'il
disait bonjour hd mais tu connais à
chaque fois je disais mais tu connais
cette personne et je comprenais jamais
en fait que c'est juste qu'il remercie
parce que je comprenais pas pourquoi il
remercie en fait est-ce qu'on lançait
pas un autre petit sujet est-ce que vous
aussi quand vous irez course avec vos
pneus repères arrivé à la caisse
abandonné elle vous dise
1 je reviens te chercher ça et vous êtes
sans stress total je vous demande de
payer en carrière est-ce que vous avez
déjà perdu vos parents dans un lieu
public et jean vous avez été appelé avec
le avec le haut parleur du magasin à
tout ce bordel
moi ça m'est jamais arrivé musique c'est
ma pire crainte quand j'étais enfant
surtout que ma mère m'ont raconté qu'il
y avait des histoires je sais pas si
j'ai jamais su si c'était pour nous
intimider ou si c'est vrai et comme quoi
les enfants qui est enlevé dans le
magasin il est fou tu es dans des
cartons il raser les cheveux
ils vendent et nos organes ans dont je
sais plus quel pays vous n'avez pas déjà
entendu ces histoires n'ont jamais
hockey une fois j'avais une bouée et
j'ai sauté et en fait j'ai levé les bras
parce que je mange ier grandement et ma
bouée et parties de mon corps et du coup
j'ai atterri dans la piscine et je me
suis mis je ne savais pas nager à
l'époque donc j'étais en boule au fond
de la piscine et il ya un mec quand
j'étais en train de mais c'est pas drôle
part dans les airs et collèges comme
quoi quand j'étais en train d'agoniser
il ya un mercato fond de la puce
qu'est ce que tu as dit damien voilà
c'est ça c'est ça c'était moi la wii
calme-toi d'amiens du coup le mec est
venu me sauver en slibard comme ça et
voilà j'aurai vraiment plus mourir noyé
ce jour là merci les mecs j'ai vu là
c'est mon champ de vision rétrécie rejet
mutuel quoi et après lui ma vie défiler
devant mes yeux et anecdotes je me
souviens sam avait traumatisé pour une
seule raison c'est que quand j'ai vu ma
vie défiler la moitié de des images
c'était juste moi qui joue à dofus
et du coup j'étais super triste je
disais plus tard si je meurs la dernière
chose que je verrai c'est mon ecaflip
niveau 30
vous savez ce qu'ils petit qui a du mal
à respirer fini par mourir
l'unc non j'en étais sûr j'aurais été
sur l'eau c'est un enfant qu'on étouffe
dans un sac plastique rien cette
question est ce que je viens d'entendre
dans son micro et briquets s'allumer
je suis plein droit du no 10 nov est-ce
que ça a la couleur de ses cheveux
damien avant avant de partir chez nous
un petit mot sur scène the way
au revoir